Harvey Gómez ha estado más de dos
semanas en la selva su misión encontrar
a cuatro niños perdidos tras un
accidente de avioneta en el que murieron
tres adultos igual que Harvey eran
indígenas huitotos y upodes uno de los
adultos era su tío Germán Mendoza un
líder social Harvey encontró la avioneta
no pidiéndole a la madre naturaleza pues
ella le ayuda los indígenas están siendo
clave en la búsqueda de los niños como
Leandro Ibáñez de la comunidad siona es
uno de los 25 guardias procedentes de
las comunidades amazónicas de caquetá y
putumayo han llegado a San José del
guaviare el centro de la operación
esperanza de rescate lo hacen Para
apoyar a las fuerzas armadas en la
búsqueda de los abuelos ancestrales que
nos guían y no abran ese espacio para
nosotros poder llegar al territorio y
encontrar aquellos niños que están
desaparecidos esta unión entre militares
y organizaciones indígenas es inédita
responde al pedido del primer gobierno
de izquierda de la historia de Colombia
los militares comparten información
mapas y los avances de la operación
después Leandro sube un bus que los
conducirá a la base aérea que les
llevará a una selva rodeada de misterios
pero que conocen bien
esperan encontrarlos un orgullo Sería
para todo Colombia y los pueblos
indígenas tras más de 20 días de
búsqueda los militares reconocen las
informaciones ancestrales para el
hallazgo de huellas y Rastros de los
niños el objetivo de indígenas y
uniformados es común buscarlos hasta
encontrar